je vais me présenter d'abord je
m'appelle l'assad en arabe on prononce
la sarthe
l'assad j'aime aussi je suis né en
tunisie et dans une ville qui s'appelle
sfax sfax en 57 était une ville l'année
de ma naissance était encore une ville
très cosmopolite
c'est à dire qu'il y avait des arabes
des français des maltais des grecs des
tunisiens juif et musulman de confession
différente tous tunisiens bien sûr
puisque les juifs tunisiens sont là
depuis le premier rang et les musulmans
tunisiens sont là depuis 1500 ans après
et je grandis dans cette atmosphère et
je voudrais je suis venu pour raconter
une partie de ceux de ce vécu qui me
semble est peut-être intéressant à
partager avec outre alors cette partie
là dans ce contexte là donc j'avais à
peu près 13 14 ans où j'ai commencé à
apprendre le coran je suis allé donc à
la mosquée apprendre le coran avoir une
éducation religieuse totalement non
canonique dans le sang ce le plus
musulman du terme et en même temps dans
mon quartier
mon copain mon ami avec lequel je
partageais toute ma en france mes rêves
et surtout les séances de cinéma chaplin
hinault il était juif et la communauté
juive tunisienne
même si elle est absolument tunisienne
ou un titre que les musulmans bien
entendu était minoritaire du point de
vue du nombre donc parfois comme j'avais
une petite taille supplémentaire sur
nino je le défends des contres les
petits copains qui essaie de le de
l'embêter tout simplement parce qu' il
n'était pas musulman
enfin c'était dans le quotidien
et ce qui me rattacher énormément à
ninon c'était le cinéma parce que tous
les tous les étés partait chez sa grand
mère et il passait les vacances d'été
chez sa grand mère à paris et donc tous
les films qui sortent et qu'on allait
recevoir en tunisie on les recevait six
mois sept mois voire un an plus tard non
prenons maintenant c'était trois mois
quatre mois
et donc quand tu es rentré de vacances
d'octobre ont commencé le 1er octobre à
l'époque
la première chose que je lui demandais
c'était alors qu'elle filmait ce que tu
as vu qu'est ce qu'on va voir cette
année et c'est donc il me racontait les
films qu'on allait par la suite voir au
cinéma le rex de sfax et puis voilà la
vie continuer comme ça puis un jour
quand je me sentais assez solides pour
poser la question à l'imam de la mosquée
solide parce que j'avais appris tout le
coran par coeur et que j'avais fait une
sorte de psalmodie qui m'avait valu le
premier prix
premier prix qui était d'ailleurs
important du point de vue financier
donc j'ai pris mon courage à deux mains
je suis allé voir notre image julie
dionne est ce que ni nous peut entrer au
paradis avec moi puisque moi j'étais
persuadé que j'avais au paradis et il
m'a dit mais qui sait ni l'eau jeudi et
coûteux leino et nous c'est mon copain
il est il est né dans une famille vivre
problème c'est qu'il n'est pas musulman
comme moi et la réponse était absolument
incroyable a dit non jeudi mère dieu est
miséricordieux
c'est ce que nous apprend il est laid la
première chose qu'on apprend c'est au
nom de dieu clément et miséricordieux
c'est pas la faute à ninon s'il est né
dans une famille juive mais il me dit
ah non mais n'a tard qu adopté l'islam
cas qu'à devenir musulman et là vous
allez entrer tous les deux au paradis
alors là je vous assure que du haut de
mes 13 ans j'avais des problèmes avec
dieu
jusque avec l'imam et je me suis dit
c'est pas possible
si moi j'étais né dans cette famille
juive
j'aurais été juif si on avait inversé le
hasard des naissances fait que les noirs
ou blancs ou juif ou chrétien et autour
de nous il y avait de tout on était dans
une dans un bonheur absolu il faut dire
ça il faut absolument que je l'appuie
parce qu'on n'arrêtait pas de faire la
fête
donc il y avait là id el-kébir les death
ride pour les musulmans ensuite il y
avait les patchs vivre ensuite il y
avait les pâques chrétiennes et chez les
chrétiens ont lavé les deux parce que
les grecs étaient orthodoxes les autres
il était catholique et ses enfants on
avait tout les tous les deux trois mois
on avait une fête religieuse et pendant
les fêtes religieuses on échangés entre
voisins autres et ça c'était absolument
formidable ouest juste ça ouais bon
l'histoire est longue
l'art est long il est le temps est court
d idées et baudelaire est donc bon
pourquoi je raconte cette histoire parce
que ça a changé complètement ma vie
parce que c'est à partir de ce moment là
je me suis dit je ne vais plus du tout
du tout du tout suivre les chemins qui
ont été tracées le chemin qui a été
tracé par ou alors qui a été prévu par
le hasard de la naissance mon chemin je
vais essayer de le suivre
2 le fond dé moi même alors je me suis
trouvé devant une multitude de chemins
absolument incroyable parce que quand on
est jeune on a envie de tout faire
je voulais faire du théâtre j'en ai fait
c'était bien c'est superbe
je voulais faire des études sont en
effet gradation jusqu'à
jusqu'à atteindre donc le haut du pavé
du professorat je suis professeur à
l'université mais je voulais également
être comédien de deux acteurs de cinéma
et je suis devenu acteur du cinéma et je
voulais ben oui absolument
c'est incroyable et je voulais être
marrant je l'ait pas fait j'ai pas eu le
temps j'appelle mais demain si la
situation où les conditions le
permettaient je le ferai et alors
aujourd'hui je me dis lorsque l'on me
pose la question qu'est ce que qu'est ce
que vous faites
alors je ne dis là présentement
immédiatement la avant-hier seulement
j'étais sur cette scène en train de
jouer ce que le dictateur n'a pas dit
donc comédien de théâtre la semaine
dernière la sortie du film appelle
j'ouvre les yeux où je joue le deuxième
mode
le film de l'est la bride donc acteurs
du cinéma avant de devenir j'ai assuré
mon dernier cours à l'université donc je
suis prof à l'université
et quand j'ai déjeuné hier avec des amis
de du monde du théâtre
on a commencé à organiser une rencontre
autour des journées théâtrales de
carthage que je dirige
c'est quelque chose d'absolument
faramineux incroyable comment peut-on
vivre toutes ces vies en même temps
comment est ce que c'est possible on
pose des questions sur la politique en
tunisie
je sais à peu près répondre sur
l'essentiel
parce que pendant dix ans de ma vie j'ai
été président de la ligue tunisienne
pour la défense des droits de l'homme à
la section de sfax rectification
importante parce que dans chaque
gouvernorat il ya une section et donc je
ne retrouve avec des versions les plus
multiple les plus incroyables et les
plus inattendus et ce n'est pas fini
si une ouverture un chemin un autre une
possibilités s'ouvraient je vous assure
que je n'hésiterai pas à l'arpenter tout
cela pour vous dire que je suis très
très très embêté par rapport à la
réponse à la question qui est posée ici
qu'elle est
et quelle peut être la version la plus
intéressante de soi alors je vais la
synthétiser en deux mots peut-être je
crois que là la version la plus
intéressante de soi c'est celle qui
permet de fonder la valeur de s'auto
fondé de ne pas se contenter d'être
ballotté par ce qui vous a été prévu ou
prédit par votre destin par votre race
par votre couleur par votre religion par
votre langue
je suis né dans une famille qui parle
tunisiens j'ai appris l'arabe
ça ne m'a pas empêché d'apprendre le
français de parler comme vous entendez
là je parle elle mange parle anglais
donc il y a bien sûr une grande fierté à
dire ce que je suis en train de dire je
suis très fier de le le communiqué mais
ce qui ce qui m'importe plus par delà le
côté dirais-je égocentrique et
d'autosatisfaction j'allais presque dire
d'autosatisfaction par référence à cet
axe je dirais donc que ce qui est plus
important c'est de véritablement de
s'orienter dans la possibilité de fonder
la valeur de fonder la capacité d'être
ce que l'on a envie d'être de ne pas
attendre à ce qu on vous dessine les
chemins que vous devez arpenter ou
les voix que vous devez suivre il est
important de sortir de ce qui vous a été
de ce qui nous a été programmée tout à
l'heure ne rien me le disait ce qui est
programmé ce qui est prédit prévu etc
c'est quelque chose qui est de l'ordre
plus de ce qui doit être dépassée de ce
qu'il doit être surpassé de ce qui doit
être donc maîtriser pour autre chose
pour un choix personnel libre et
responsable
il y a des valeurs importantes qui ont
été développées dans les années 60 et 70
et qui aujourd'hui dans la culture
marchande qui est la culture la plus la
plus diffuse un peu partout dans le
monde
la valeur de la liberté et de la
responsabilité a été porté par sartre
par les les existentialistes et par
l'existentialisme en général je pense
que c'est quelque chose qui est encore
un véritable moteur de l'existence il
est très important d'être libre et
responsable
laliberté n'implique pas une anarchie
totale mais implique également une
dimension responsable importante et en
cela le choix qui a été celui d'un
groupe allant chercher des réfugiés en
syrie ou de consacrer une année de sa
vie pour sauver des vies en péril ou de
jeter des jalons et des ponts
humanitaire pour insister sur le fait
que notre monde meilleur est possible
grâce à la générosité de chacun grâce à
l'implication de chacun devrait être à
mon sens la version la plus intéressante
de soi parce que si on nous réduit
on essaie de nous réduire à une sorte de
d'individus qui ne fait que
consommer qui n'est que une valeur
marchande qui naquit lui qui n'est pas
capable de fonder une valeur humaine
cela est extrêmement réducteur et
extrêmement appauvrissant et donc la vie
est formidable elle vaut la peine d'être
vécue
et on peut avoir quantitativement 60 ans
de vie mais en 60 ans on peut avoir
multiplié intensifiée au maximum ce vécu
et le x 10 et donc vivre quelque chose
comme six cents ans en 60 ans en mars et
c'est ces strates et en faisant tous les
choix possibles et en états et on est
pense surtout capable de sortir de du
giro de soi même le petit soi-même pour
être non pas un citoyen d'une nation
d'une ville d'une culture d'une religion
mais un véritable de citoyens du monde
merci